ce restaurateur un peu rustre mais très
attachant nous l'avons tous croisé un
jour jacques joué par jean claude
dreyfus est à la retraite et sans le sou
sa fille léa incarnée par julia
duchaussoy l'héberge dans sa maison
provençale
un jour elle lui rend visite pour lui
annoncer son mariage avec fahed
restaurateurs d'un autre genre le
prétendant est cuisinier il est dans la
cuisine quand vous dite moléculaire la
cuisine moléculaire que gilles
moléculaire c'est ce que jacques a
jamais connue en fait c'est quand même
une cuisine qui est beaucoup plus
contemporain et moderne aux conflits de
générations entre les deux cuisiniers
bien se mêler à une affaire de gros sous
pour monter leur propre restaurant
léa et son fiancé ont besoin de vendre
la maison où habite jacques une intrigue
légère mais non dénué de fond ya le
plaisir de la comédie comme on le disait
comme jean-claude le disait là et puis
il ya aussi ce petit fond de tendresse
et puis dont on va pas dire de réflexion
c'est pas le but du jeu mais a tout de
même un petit peu quand même
d'ailleurs on est en période de
l'électoral la plus ou moins donc ça
peut faire réfléchir et faire du bien
peut-être cette étude d'amour celui sur
lui-même et d'amour donc ça peut
peut-être réviser aux gens 2 est voté
vêtements yade toute cette petite
réflexion sur l'amour est plus important
que les différences dans cette pièce
senteurs et couleurs se mélangent sur
fond d'ambiance provençal mais la mise
en scène rythmée dan bouvier ne laisse
rien au hasard tout est précis un tout
et x vraiment très très près si on ne
déroge pas à certaines choses reaser en
plus c'est difficile quand il faut faire
la cuisine toucher des objets là donc on
en est c'est très très paisible si vous
avez manqué la présentation de montigny
le bretonneux
vous pourrez retrouver ce trio infernal
pour d'autres dates près de paris la
tournée se poursuit également dans toute
la france